das hier ist das siebte Video der
siebenteiligen Interviewserie mit den
Teilnehmern von Seven vs wild Staffel 2
viel Spaß mit dem Interview von knossi
das hier ist übrigens die wirklich
letzte Folge von mir and the seasons
wenn ihr aber immer noch nicht genug von
Seven vs world Staffel 2 haben solltet
checkt den ersten Link in der
Videobeschreibung und ricos Fotobücher
aus viel Spaß damit Malibu orange
wir sind wieder da
frisch zweimal geduscht zweimal
und da kam direkt raus
zweimal geduscht gleich kommen noch mal
ey das war unfassbar weiß ich mit viel
Fingernägel nicht ganz sauber geworden
aber das mit der Zeit wird
wahrscheinlich gehen es ist unglaublich
jetzt man hat es geschafft man ist hier
ist unfassbar wie hast du dich auf deine
Teilnahme von Seven vs world Staffel 2
vorbereitet ja ich habe mir auf die
Teilnahme vorbereitet insofern dass ich
halt ein paar Trainings gemacht habe mit
Survival Martin der letztes Jahr in
Schweden der Woche überstanden tropische
gefüllte konnten wir jetzt nicht
wirklich machen ich war in so einer
Auffangstation mal die Tiere
kennenlernen ich habe sowas habe ich
gemacht wie man mit den Sachen umgeht
mit einem Feuerstahl mit meinen
Gegenständen halt wie ich es aufhängen
wie ich es mache wir hatten noch andere
Pläne mit so einem Tab Gott sei Dank ich
sag's ja an der Stelle Martin das wäre
dann nicht gegangen gott sei Dank ist
das schiefgegangen ich wäre am Arsch
gewesen da war nicht einfach an meinem
Spotify ein bisschen was hin das war
alles lebensgefährlich über mir
Kokosnüsse ich habe teilweise das drei
Meter von mir Boom und ich dachte ich
wirklich kennt mich erwischen können
also ich war das war meine Vorbereitung
und mental wirklich mental Willenskraft
das war ich habe immer Willenskraft
Willenskraft Willenskraft wenn du was
willst komm umso krasser dass du es ohne
explizit Vorbereitung durchgezogen hast
eine weitere Sache auf die sich keiner
von euch vorbereiten konnte war der
extremere drop off wie war der Tag für
dich ich bin gestorben in meinem Leben
das erste Mal
ich soll vom Helikopter springen pass
auf wir kommen hin an diesen Airport
landen da auf einmal stehen da drei
Helis ich denke es kann nicht dein Ernst
sein wirklich dann reite den Heli und
ich denke schon das ist alles hier ganz
komisch die drei Heelys fliegen
nebeneinander wie gestört und kriegst
wenn sich jetzt da einer nur die
Geräusche sitzt da drin wenn die sich
unter Kontrolle haben du hat der hat ja
keine Augen hinten der andere wenn der
eine nur ein bisschen für dann ist schon
mal eh alles vorbei dann heißt es Jovan
nee wie heißt er Joris springt zuerst
ich verlasse mich da drauf wir kommen
irgendwann auf einmal heißt nicht dass
du springst zuerst habe mich vertan
ich gucke aus der Höhe und denk mir
wirklich Turmspringen war wirklich ein
Dreck dagegen ich stehe davor aber bin
dann einfach zielgerecht habe Fritz
angeguckt Otto macht so bei mir nur so
echt komm ich bin raus zack
so das war der Moment Schatz da haben
wir immer gedacht weißt doch wie ich so
vorgespielt habe wenn wirklich
Helikopter ist und hat sie immer Mitleid
gehabt so oh nein oh nein schlimm und
dann komme ich zwar unfassbar ich komme
erstmal unter Wasser
bis wieder hochgekommen in voller Montur
ich habe meine meine Safari Mütze da
drunter noch die regenkappe drüber alles
zu weil ich dachte irgendwie das ist
wahrscheinlich richtig alle meine sehr
gut sehr gut ich komme bisschen wieder
oben war überhaupt erstmal realisiert
habe was hier abgeht dann das Zeichen
geben alles ist okay ich sehe die
Helikopter Kreisen weiter ich denke mal
gut als ich dann merke ich diese Gewalt
des Ozean ich habe nie erlebt seitdem
ich habe auch echt Probleme gehabt dann
noch mal irgendwie ins Meer wirklich
reinzugehen das war und dann schwimme
mich geht ich schlug Wasser es geht
nicht wieder eine Welt die mich die mich
trifft es geht nicht ich habe einfach
ich habe teilweise echt aufgegeben ich
habe das noch nie gehabt dass mein Leben
an mir vorbeigezogen ist was erste Mal
dass ich gedacht habe okay
jetzt geht's zu Ende der Weg war
aussichtslos es war so weit ihr habt
doch selbst gesehen es war echt soweit
ich habe dann unter Wasser ich hatte
eine gopra also mir alles scheißegal hat
mich nicht mehr ich musste irgendwie in
diesem kleinen das habe ich mich dann
bin ich irgendwann habe ich mich so
ausgeruht habe gemerkt geht nicht wieder
vorwärts und dann kann ich mich nicht
mehr erinnern wie ich ausgestiegen bin
aus dem Strich kann mir einfach nicht
erinnern ich weiß es nicht ich weiß nur
dass ich echt einmal so na tot Erfahrung
hatte das erste Mal es war wirklich
krass
also das war echt heftig ihr denkt jetzt
den Scheiß aber es war echt heftig ja
was habt ihr denn von oben gedacht als
sie mich gesehen habt
es war wirklich ich war wirklich tot
einmal ich habe an mein Kind gedacht ich
habe die Familie gedacht das wird alles
gut du hast viel erlebt du hast nur
hinterlässt hier gute Dinge alles wird
gut dann ist es jetzt so das habe ich
echt gedacht dachte dann soll zu sein
dann ist es halt in der Show
dann komme ich an an der Insel ich weiß
nicht wie ich erinnere mich noch dass
ich irgendwie liege
dann gucke ich so es hat alles so viel
Kraft gekostet weißt du wie ich fertig
war auch die ganze Woche über hat sich
ein Muskelkater in mir gezogen ein
unfassbarer Muskelkater von dieser
Überanstrengung ich bin ja kein
sportlicher Typ ich habe keinen Sport
gemacht oder so wenn Sascha das passiert
wahrscheinlich kein Problem der merkt
der merkt nichts aber ich hatte ich war
fertig und dann weiß ich noch wie ich
mich irgendwie
irgendwie zu einem felsenziehe zu einem
Baum und jedes Mal bestimmt gefühlt ich
weiß nicht ob es so war eine halbe
Stunde erstmal liege einfach fertig und
dann sehe ich irgendwann meinen roten
Sack und das waren vielleicht zwei Meter
oder so habe mich lange überwinden
müssen auch darüber zu krabbeln
das war echt brutal es war wirklich
brutal als ich gar keinen Bock mehr auf
Heli Flug über Las Vegas oder so scheiße
das Ganze gleich abschminken ich bin
immer wieder untergegangen ich weiß
nicht ob man es gesehen hatten immer
wieder und immer wieder Salzwasser immer
wieder immer wieder Salz Wasser
und dann dachte und dann habe ich noch
kurz zu Überlegung habe weiß ich noch
schmeißt die Schuhe ab dann denke ich
mir aber wie willst du ohne Schuhe ja
weitermachen so bringt das überhaupt was
und dann weiter
boah Alter ey das war dass man das mal
erlebt also hätte ich jetzt drauf
verzichten können
aber danach soll ich dir ehrlich auch
den Tag drauf dachte ich es ist dieser
Far Cry 3 Moment Flugzeug an Land
gespült werden es ist genau dieser
Moment ne weiß was ich meine dieser Tom
Hanks moment du bist fix und fertig
Landes an dem Strand irgendwie hat es
dann auch wieder was gehabt ne und ich
wusste ich bin unter kontrolliert der
Situation es kann mir eigentlich nichts
passieren da springen ja ein paar Leute
raus und und dann aber Alter was dein
Kopf dir sagt war krass kannst du uns
noch mal kurz erzählen wie es am Morgen
das aussetzt Tages dazu gekommen ist das
Sascha und du um 10.000 € gewettet haben
wir saßen morgens beim letzten Frühstück
letzte Frühstück Henkers Mahlzeit und
ich denke mir das geilste war ich extra
noch an der Tankstelle angehalten in
Deutschland schön alles gekauft was es
gibt ne wie viel Euro
hat jemand bock nein auch später noch
als wir es noch durf nein ich die Tüte
aber selber auch kein Junge mehr gehabt
wir frühstücken wir frühstücken schön
gemütlich Zack und dann sage wir müssen
uns doch hier ich habe mir schon so viel
Druck aufgebaut ich habe meine Freundin
einfliegen lassen ja
ich hätte eigentlich hätte sie auch die
ganze Zeit über hier verbringen können
aber stell dir mal vor was das mit
meinem Kopf macht ich denke mir nach
einer Stunde bin ich bei dir wir machen
uns einen schönen Abend trink mal lieber
orange aber hat mir gedacht nee die soll
der Flug wird annulliert wenn ich
aufgebe wenn ich Code yellow mache Code
Red wäre okay gewesen ne ich mir
irgendwie das Bein abgehackt dann wäre
es okay gewesen aber Code yellow meine
Psyche dann geht's nicht deshalb kommen
eigentlich wollte ich mit trymacs Wetten
aber irgendwie kein Netz mehr und sowas
schade Geld gespart Max Geld gespart und
dann habe ich gesagt Sascha komm 10.000
€ Wetter wer länger macht unser Sascha
und wir haben 10.000 € Wetter gemacht
und es war war irgendwie was krass ich
habe es dann aber komplett vergessen
erst am Tag 5 ist mir wieder eingefallen
damit Sascha gerettet ich habe gar nicht
mehr drüber nachgedacht nichts und ein
Tag fünf ist mir gekommen und ich wusste
aber das ist eine Wette
die kann nur ich verlieren maximal aber
ich dachte es für uns beide gut aber ihn
hat sehr beschäftigt den ganzen bis wir
abgeflogen bis 10.000 Euro
richtigen Schub gegeben ich finde sowas
gut warum nicht scheiße werde ich mit
trymacs 10000 € Gewinn
eine lange Zeit wisst nicht schaffen für
ein Content mache ich die Wette
das hier
hatte ich nicht bei mir die Geräusche
weißt du was ich hatte
Wildschweine aber nicht gesehen aber
Sounds waren da du kommst an und erstmal
ist alles gut am Tag 3 schlägt das
Wetter langsam um und die ersten
Tropenstürme gehen los wie war das für
dich
wo denn
verdammte Scheiße so sehen die aus ich
habe die gerufen mit meinem Lockruf
guck doch ich habe den wirklich mit
meinem Logo
die kommt runter die will so was sind
denn los
komm
runter das ist nicht Pumba aus
Dschungelbuch solchen meine Armdrücken
Schatz ich kann mit Tiere der der wohnt
wahrscheinlich hier der gehört hier zum
Resort oder was die Macht zeigen den der
hat wahrscheinlich auch Namen so sehen
die aus ich habe sie nur gehört bei mir
am Lager oh geil geil ist hier aber
einfach weiter mit dem Schwein im
Hintergrund kommt ich habe viel Tonner
und Blitze im in in Erinnerung es war
krass Tag drei die ersten beiden dachte
ich wow das geht alles paar Probleme
gehabt weil ich die Hängematte auf um
nicht erschlagen zu werden und so auch
gleich Fehler gemacht bei der Flut
aufgehangen und all die diese üblichen
Problem weil keiner hat hier Ebbe und
Flut Coaching ich habe keine Ahnung
irgendwann hast du die Gezeiten gecheckt
man kommt Wassermann nicht aber dann auf
einmal kommt dieses ich habe ich habe
nur noch Himmel geguckt ne das war meine
einzige Aufgabe ich hatte kein Dach kein
nichts meine Strategie war ich schlafe
wann die Insel mich lässt das war meine
Strategie und dann bei Regen
aufgestanden sofort raus Hängematte
trocken lassen erst später komme einfach
abmachen können und dann später und
trocknen und später wieder aufhängen
nicht so weit bin ich auch nicht
irgendwann fehlt ja auch die Kraft und
sowas und darum bin ich wenn ich raus
Blitz und Donnerstag ist für Kinder
ich habe ohne Dach habe ich sieben
Nächte da geschlafen und ich in jedem
ich habe in jedem Moment habe ich
gedacht okay mein Ziel ist nur noch
Himmel beobachten und es zieht so
schnell auf und ich habe immer gedacht
immer ich lege kurzen hängen was und
denke boah ich sehe gerade Sterne geil
geschlafen gefühlt 10 15 Minuten wieder
als noch Sterne da das ich habe nur noch
Himmel Beobachtung war alles was ich
gemacht habe ich habe nur noch ich habe
überall gesehen wenn Gewitter vom weiten
Mann ich bin Wetter riologe oder wie
heißt das war wirklich so ich habe nur
geguckt wie das Wetter kommt und dann
habe ich danach gelebt
aber ey ja weil ich nichts kann ich bin
kein Dachdecker ich kann kein Dach bauen
wo ich die die anderen abgeholt haben
ich sehe ich sehe die ganze Dinger
dachte ich krass ich habe kein Dach
gebaut ich habe gleich zieh ohne durch
was war in der Zeit dein größtes Problem
womit hattest du in der gesamten Zeit am
meisten zu kämpfen die meisten würden
jetzt denken wahrscheinlich Zigaretten
es war gar kein Problem für mich
war man so viel mit sich mit der ganzen
Situation kämpft weil man so mit anderen
Sachen beschäftigt ist es sind so
Kleinigkeiten die deinen Tag einfach so
zu die Probleme machen so wann trocknest
du die Kleider die Kleider vorne ist der
Stein ich wusste genau welche Steine
zuerst in der Sonne sind wo ich schnell
versuchen kann Kleider richtig trocken
ist nichts geworden aber du bist so sehr
mit solchen Sachen beschäftigt dann
kommt noch die Challenge dass du gar
nicht an Zigaretten denkst ich habe es
gab aber Tage wie Tag drei ich weiß ich
glaube Tag 3 da habe ich zwei kippen
geraucht weil die ganze Situation mit
dem Wetter und so meine ich glaube ich
keine grau es gab Tage also immer
Situationsabhängig aber das war gar
nicht was mir gefehlt hat was hat dir
gefehlt was hat mich geschafft was hat
mir gefehlt weißt du was mir nicht
gefehlt hat mein Handy das hat mich so
erstaunt das hat mir nicht gefehlt wir
haben einfach Menschen gefehlt und
Stahlbeton umgekehrte Straßen das war
echt so wo ich dachte weil untenstuhl
Möbel es ist so wie du weißt ich habe es
dann irgendwann geschafft dass ich echt
zehn Minuten auf dem Stein liege kurz
einschlafe oder auf so einer gekrümmten
Palme
ich bin danach
ich habe mir alle Knochen gebrochen du
hast wehgetan aber ich konnte 10 Minuten
machen weil ich die Nacht nicht
geschlafen habe so war das für mich das
war mein Abenteuer aber ich sag dir
wirklich nicht gefehlt hat mir mein
Handy und Termine das war ganz anders
natürlich hat mir gefehlt Frau und
vermisst Frau brauche ich nicht sagen
das ist ja wohl das ist das Wichtigste
die geliebten Menschen um einen weil man
immer dachte oh Mann wie was wie würden
diese was würden die jetzt sagen wenn
Sie das Sehen stell dir mal vor die
jemand ist dabei du bist dabei oder so
guckst dir das an wie würden wir das
machen kannst vergessen tausend damals
darüber kannst vergessen
wirklich das war krass und gibt es
irgendwas dass du Positives für Dich aus
dieser Zeit mitnimmst das mal ab und zu
ich komme doch du weißt doch selber ich
komme aus so einem Turbo Leben in dem du
ich glaube ich habe es auch einmal in
der Kamera gesagt ich war manchmal hat
man auch Momente gehabt
ich sag das auch glaube ich irgendwann
die Kamera dass ich nicht mehr weiß ob
ich das in die Kammer gesagt habe und
ich habe auch nur mit mir selbst
gesprochen oder ob ich das nur für mich
kenne ich war manchmal da stinksauer mit
dem Pazifik das habe ich aber glaube ich
nicht gefilmt ich war einfach stinksauer
hau ab jetzt warum jetzt so warum hat
jemand an der Erde gedreht und heute
kommt die Flut später warum ich bin es
abends abends sieht sich an den Stein
nein ich war sauer mit dem Pazifik ich
habe den Gast wirklich wie die Pest und
dann wusste ich manchmal nicht habe ich
das wirklich in die Kamera gesagt oder
habe ich das nur für mich gesagt ich
habe permanent ich habe permanent über
über mit Leuten geredet die auch nicht
da waren ich hatte waren Vorstellung was
war die Frage noch mal
was Positives aus der Woche aus der
Woche mit dass man wirklich bei dem
Leben wie ich habe bei dem du aufwachst
hast 50 WhatsApp Nachrichten hast
irgendwie zehn Termine drei calls dass
man ab und zu wirklich so eine Auszeit
braucht und ich hatte die bestimmt wie
viel Jahre hatte ich das nicht
viele viele Jahre hatte ich sowas nicht
ich habe Urlaube gemacht ganz normal
aber die Urlaube sind trotzdem es ist
trotzdem musste Telefon musste machen
dass er kein ist das war wirklich das
erste Mal dass ich rausgekommen bin aus
dem und mich mit ganz anderen Dingen
beschäftigt habe das war ganz neuer
Erfahrung für mich
hättest du auch haben können
mein Handy heute ich komme hier an oh
WiFi geht nicht alle heulen ich denke
mir er bringt mir mein Handy ich denke
mir
ich wollte nur meine Mutter anrufen die
haben anrufen im Satelliten Telefon und
mein Handy habe ich einfach immer noch
da unten liegen ich habe sich mal nicht
mal mit zum Bungalow weil es mir so
uninteressant ist ich weiß da warten
einige auf Nachrichten aber das reicht
auch noch das habe ich echt gelernt das
hat übermorgen
voll entspannt mich interessiert gerade
gar nichts ich muss nicht gucken weil
ich muss jetzt keine Instagram Stories
gucken ich muss nicht gucken was ist in
den Twitter Trends ich gucke nicht was
läuft bei Youtube ab es ist mir
scheißegal und das war hier echt so und
das war wirklich für mich glaube ich mal
ein wichtiges wichtiges Erlebnis würdest
du deinen Freunden deiner Familie deinen
Ängsten Leuten so eine Erfahrung mal
empfehlen nein doch würde ich
es kommt drauf an also in meiner
Freundin würde ich jetzt nicht empfehlen
meine Mutter sagt alles kein Problem
aber es wäre sie natürlich wir sind eine
Camper Familie wir waren früher auf dem
Campingplatz nee Campingplatz Oberbruch
schön mit einem Wohnwagen und einem
Vorzelt jedes Wochenende das ist anders
also die sagen immer alle alle dass da
kein Problem irgendwas machst du schon
oder die Frau die uns geimpft hat ne
machst du die ganz kleine Problem
findest du alles ja es ist so nicht es
ist ganz anders als man sich vorgestellt
hat und ich würde wirklich
nur echt empfehlen das ist nicht einfach
was man mal schnell macht ich würde es
Leuten empfehlen die meinen sie haben
die Kraft sie haben die Kraft das
durchzustehen ich glaube was auch viel
gesagt wurde das hat mir Martin oft
gesagt der hat gemeint worden Tag 3 Tag
wie kommen solche Dämonen in dir hoch so
Sachen von früher das kann bei mir nicht
bei mir kam gar nichts Negatives nichts
ich habe die ganze Zeit Gefühl gehabt
bei mir ist alles top zu Hause ist alles
top ich hatte keinen negatives Gefühl
ich wusste alles läuft einzige Sorge war
hat die Frau den Reisepass eingesteckt
wenn Sie zum Flughafen fährt das war das
einzige was ich so gedacht habe
ansonsten ich hatte nur positive Vibes
und habe mit mir selbst gekämpft aber
trotzdem werde ich der langweiligste
Kandidat sein glaube ich weil alle da
draußen haben erwartet sie erleben jetzt
hier knossi deine riesen Show abzieht es
war nicht eine knossyshow es war
wirklich Jens Heinz Richard knossalla
wirklich ich war wie ich bin ich habe
die Sachen gesagt wie ich bin ich habe
ich habe nichts auf lustig da gemacht
das werden die Leute ja sehen sondern
ich habe einfach dokumentiert wie ich
das hier mache
und das war's bevor du diese Reise
angetreten hast gab es einiges an hate
und eine Menge Leute die nicht verstehen
konnten warum du Teil dieses Format bist
wie war das für dich ey habe ich auch
thematisiert in der in den in den Videos
ich habe irgendwann habe ich mal die
kann man die Hand genommen und habe den
Leuten gesagt hey
dieser ganze mann sollte nicht ähm und
das haben wir erlebt Nova und ich wir
waren die gehatetesten sagt man so
gehatetesten gut das war wir waren die
die
Kandidaten also vor allem weil die Leute
natürlich da wow es ist ihre Show es ist
alles habe ich jetzt gegen das Mikro
entschuldigung es ist alles eines Show
das Gucken alles survival interessierte
Leute und dann kommen da Leute aus dem
show business rein klar dann macht man
nicht gleich da denkt man oh Kacke kacke
aber ich finde echt wichtig und das habe
ich oft gemerkt und das mache ich zum
Beispiel nicht Leute haben ein kurzes
Bild ein kurzen Ausschnitt von dir und
schließen sich gleich eine Meinung ein
Bild von dir was vielleicht gar nicht
stimmt weil sie eine kurze Info gesehen
haben wo du vielleicht gerade irgendwie
in einem 30 Sekunden Clip wo was ganz
anderes abläuft und du dir sofort ein
Bild von einem Menschen machst
das stört mich immer und das sage ich
den Leuten auch immer auch in meinen
Streams macht das nicht versucht das
abzulegen geht vorurteillos da dran
lasst euch einfach überraschen und ich
hoffe die Leute haben mich jetzt mal
anders kennengelernt hey und ich will
noch sagen
wirklich das habe ich auch mehrfach
gesagt ich war in vielen Fernsehshows
ich war wirklich ich habe ich hätte ins
Dschungelcamp gehen können die bieten
mir das jedes Jahr an Promi Big Brother
sonst was nichts habe ich davon gemacht
weil diese Show hier für mich meiner
Meinung nach da hat keine Fernseher
mithalten die beste Show der Welt ist
und deswegen bedeutet es mir so viel da
dabei gewesen zu sein es ist die beste
Show es gibt keine Show mehr die
wirklich real ist außer diese hier bei
allem wird irgendwie mitgepfuscht das
hier ist eins zu eins was hier passiert
die Leute sind auf sich alleine gelassen
mit zwei Kameras und ey dieser Show kann
man noch vertrauen und es war für mich
eine Ehre in dieser Show zu sein vielen
Dank und herzlichen Glückwunsch zu
sieben geschafften Tagen aber es war
wirklich so ich habe gesagt die beste
Show der Welt
[Musik]